good afternoon and welcome my colleagues
and I have one overarching goal to
sustain the economic expansion with a
strong job market and stable prices for
the benefit of the American people at
the FOMC meeting that concluded today we
maintained our policy interest rate but
made some significant changes to our
statement since the beginning of the
year we have judged that our current
policy stance was broadly appropriate
and that we should be patient in
assessing the need for any changes in
light of increased uncertainties and
muted inflation pressures we now
emphasize that the committee will
closely monitor the implications of
incoming information for the economic
outlook and will act as appropriate to
sustain the expansion with a strong
labor market and inflation near its 2
percent objective I'd like to take it a
step back and review how the changing
economic and financial picture brings us
to today's decision so far this year the
economy has performed reasonably well
with solid fundamentals supporting
continued growth and strong employment
inflation has been running somewhat
below our objective but we've expected
it to pick up supported by solid growth
in a strong job market along with this
favourable picture we've been mindful of
some ongoing crosscurrents including
trade developments and concerns about
global growth at the time of our last
FOMC meeting which ended on May 1 there
was tentative evidence that these cross
currents were moderating the latest data
from China and Europe were encouraging
and there were reports of progress in
trade negotiations with China our
continued continued patience stance
seemed appropriate in the cabinet
committee saw no strong case for
adjusting our policy rate in the week
since our last meeting the cross
currents have re-emerged growth
indicators from around the world have
disappointed on net raising concerns
about the strength of the global economy
apparent progress on trade turn to
greater uncertainty and our contacts in
business and agricultural report
heightened concerns over trade
developments
these concerns may have contributed to
the drop in business confidence in some
recent surveys and may be starting to
show through to incoming data risk
sentiment and financial markets has
deteriorated as well against this
backdrop inflation remains muted while
the baseline outlook remains favorable
the question is whether these
uncertainties will continue to weigh on
the outlook and this call for additional
monetary policy accommodation many FOMC
participants now see that the case for
somewhat more accommodative policy has
strengthened let me explain the basis
for this judgment starting with the
outlook for jobs and growth participants
see unemployment remaining low this year
and next monthly job gains in May were
lower than expected however and in light
of recent developments this bears
watching still many labor market
indicators remain strong community
business and labor leaders all tell us
that the prospects for job seekers have
seldom been better and that this is true
even for those who have traditionally
struggled to find work wages are rising
and is this particularly so for lower
paying jobs committee participants
growth projections from 2019 our little
revised for March with a central
tendency of to 22.2% just above their
estimates of longer-run normal growth
the growth projections for the year as a
whole masks some important details about
the composition of growth annual growth
will be boosted by the surprisingly
strong first quarter which had just been
reported at the time of the May FOMC
meeting as I noted then the unexpected
strength was largely in net exports and
inventories components that are not
generally reliable indicators of ongoing
momentum the more reliable drivers of
growth in the economy are spending on
consumption and business investment
while consumption was weak in the first
quarter incoming data show that has it
has bounced back and is now running at a
solid pace
in contrast the limited evidence
available at this time
suggests that growth in business fixed
income has slowed in the second quarter
moreover manufacturing production has
posted declines
for this year thus while the baseline
outlook remains favorable many FOMC
participants cited the investment
picture and weaker business sentiment
and the cross currents I mentioned
earlier as supporting their judgment
that the risk of less favorable outcomes
has risen after running close to our
symmetric two percent objective for most
of last year inflation declined in the
first quarter data since then shows some
pickup participants broadly see
inflation moving back up toward our 2
percent objective but at a slower pace
than had been expected the central
tendency for 2019 core inflation which
emits volatile food and energy
components is between one point seven
and one point eight percent setting
aside short-term fluctuations committee
participants expressed concerns about
the pace of inflation to return to two
percent wages are rising as noted above
but not at a pace that would provide
much upward impetus to inflation
moreover weaker global growth may
continue to hold inflation down around
the world we are firmly committed to our
symmetric 2 percent inflation objective
and we are well aware that inflation
weakness that persists even in a healthy
economy could precipitate a difficult to
arrest downward drift and longer run
inflation expectations because there are
no definitive measures of inflation
expectations we must rely on imperfect
proxies market-based measures of
inflation compensation have moved down
since our May meeting and some survey
based expectations measures are near the
bottom of their historic ranges
combining these factors with the risks
to growth already noted participants
expressed concerns about a more
sustained sustained shortfall of
inflation overall our policy discussions
focused on the appropriate response to
the uncertain environment the
projections of appropriate policies show
that many participants believe that some
cut in the federal funds rate will be
appropriate in the scenario that they
see as most likely though some
participants wrote down policy cuts and
others did not our deliberations made
clear that a number of those who wrote
down a flat rate path agree that the
case for additional accommodation has
strengthened since our May meeting
this anatomic accommodation would
support economic activity and
inflation's returned to our objective
uncertainties surrounding the baseline
outlook have clearly risen since our
last meeting it's important however that
monetary policy not overreact to any
individual data point or short-term
swing in sentiment doing so would risk
adding even more uncertainty to the
outlook thus my colleagues and I will be
looking to see whether these
uncertainties will continue to weigh on
the outlook and we will use our tools as
appropriate to sustain the expansion
thank you I will be pleased to take your
questions Nick timorous of The Wall
Street Journal
chair Powell did you consider a rate cut
today specifically was it one of the
options the policy options in the teal
book and is the committee considering
moving given all of the uncertainty you
addressed moving it's changing its
policy before the next meeting so the
committee had you know our usual long
discussion of global and domestic
economic and financial conditions and
then spent this morning talking about
monetary policy and came to the view
that that I expressed to you which is
that we're gonna be monitoring
monitoring the cross currents and the
other items that we've mentioned but
that we'd like to see more going forward
particularly we'd like to see whether
these risks continue to weigh on the
outlook so generally as I mentioned many
on the committee do see a strengthened
case eight of those strengthened case
for cutting rates aid actually wrote
down rate cuts a number of others see
that the case is strengthened but the
committee wanted to wanted to see more
as I mentioned and and I also mentioned
that some of these some of these
developments have been of quite recent
vintage and so we do expect that we'll
be learning a lot more on all of these
issues in the near term and
and that's our focus and do you think
something could change before the next
meeting I'm sure that things will change
before the next meeting I expect a full
range of data and information on all of
these issues that we are looking at I
think we'll learn a great deal more
about them and I think that's we think
that that's the right way to to move
here again many of these developments
happen you know part of the way through
the the last intermediate only seven
weeks ago we had a great jobs report and
came out of the last FOMC meeting
feeling that the economy and our policy
was in a good place so we want to see we
want to see and we want to react to
developments and trends that are
sustained that are that are genuine and
not react just two data points or just
to changes in sentiment which can chew
which can which can be volatile at the
same time we're quite mindful of the
risks to the outlook and are prepared to
move and use our tools as needed to
sustain the expansion mr. chairman Steve
Liesman CNBC um could you walk us
through your thinking about trade it was
really the threat of tariffs against
Mexico that caused at least the market
to become definitively Bankura or
pricing in rate cuts if for example
there's a deal with China does that take
the possibility of rate cuts off the
table yeah so I would say that we're not
looking at any any one thing I guess I
would start by agreeing with your
premise that news about trade has been
an important driver of sentiment in the
intermediate period but we're also
looking at global growth it's really
trade developments and concerns about
global growth that are that are on our
minds so we're not exclusively focused
on one event or one piece of data risks
seem to have grown in the meantime we
have incoming data in the United States
that's been pretty good particularly for
the consumer consumer spending is solid
supported by you know a healthy job
market high levels of employment wages
going up
we do see those some areas that we're
looking at such as I mentioned business
fixed income so also the prolonged
shortfall in inflation and perhaps job
growth we don't like to look at one job
report we like to average over three or
six months but still that bears watching
so we'll be monitoring the implications
of all of those developments for the US
economic outlook we expect to learn a
good deal more as I mentioned and we'll
be asking the question whether those
risks are gonna continue to weigh on the
outlook and then in the end we'll will
use our tools as appropriate to sustain
this long expansion from the Washington
Post could you clarify what you would do
if the president tweets or calls you to
say he would like to demote you as Fed
chair I am I think the law is clear that
I have a four-year term and I fully
intend to serve it
Hydra pal I was hoping that this is
genius my luck from the New York Times I
was hoping that you could clarify for us
a little bit how you're thinking about
the risks of waiting too long to cut
rates versus the risks of cutting rates
prematurely sort of what the balance of
risks are and how you talk about that
right so we're always trying to balance
that risk but I would say that given the
the quite recent nature of some of the
events I think the committee felt though
though that the right thing to do was to
wait and see more and we will see a lot
more on all these issues in the very
near term so I don't think the risk of
waiting too long is prominent right now
I would say as a general matter it's
always something that we we have to
weigh but I think we believe that that
the right thing here is to is to watch
carefully in the near term and see how
these risks unfold and see whether they
continue to weigh on the outlook
obviously we try to avoid going
prematurely as well in this case you
know there's always some judgment in
these things but I would just say that
that the the risks that we see having
emerged are our risks that have gotten
our attention and that have called a
number of us to write down rate cuts and
a number of those who haven't to see
that the case is strengthened
Marty crutsinger with EAP you had your
first descent and in your time as
chairman how does that give us a sense
that there was debate among a group that
was pushing for a rate cut this time and
and and and how do you do you expect
further dissents going forward let me
say the same thing as I as I said last
time before they're advantageous and
that is that I think the process of
careful thoughtful dissent is very
healthy one and I've always believed
that and I feel like you make better
decisions when you hear a disparity of
views so I I really do look at at at it
that way I would add though that the
support for the path we took for the
policy statement that we adopted was was
quite broad
James politi with the Financial Times
Mario Draghi at the ECB yesterday sent
us strong signal of new stimulus for the
eurozone do you think that such actions
to ease policy at other central banks
around the world will put more pressure
on the Fed to do the same well I think
first I think all central banks are
focused on their domestic mint their
mandates are domestic and they're
focused on economic conditions from a
domestic standpoint and that it goes for
the European Central Bank goes for the
Fed goes for all central banks so that's
that's our principal focus so it could
cut either way you know III would think
that to extent you see stronger
financial conditions and stronger
activity in the ECB after a rate cut
that would that would support tend to
support activity so we're really focused
on on you know the risks to our on the
baseline outlook which is Silla pretty
favorable one and what and the risks to
those outlooks that's that's our
principal focus this is a the first time
that you've been really issuing seps in
an era when rates are going to be going
down I
- sort of related questions is there
concern that you'll be causing a sort of
dot deflation by telling people we'll
don't buy your car now because it'll get
cheaper in six months because we're
cutting rates and that that could sort
of fulfill itself and secondly on
inflation that was a pretty big drop in
expected PCE yet you know without
reacting to it
are you not sort of undermining your own
credibility in terms of commitment to
the two percent target I'll take the
inflation when first I didn't quite
follow your dot question from one point
eight to how much nine with words went
from one point eight to one point five
that's the fact that you're not
responding that's the inflation question
yes I'm saying you know the fact that
you've signaled rate cuts are coming or
it is was there any concern on the
committee that this would tell consumers
tell people don't borrow now don't spend
now because nice a good overlay right
okay so let me let me answer the
inflation question first so we're saying
that we know I noted in the statement
and also in my my what I what I said
here we saw that market-based measures
of inflation expectations breakevens
dropped we noted that also in in the
statement and I noted it as a reason for
us to one of one of several reasons why
why it feels to us that the case for
more accommodation has strengthened so
we find that notable not only that the
the actual forecast for inflation for
this year among FOMC FOMC participants
dropped a couple of tenths so that means
a more prolonged shortfall of inflation
let me say on inflation it's it's
something I've been concerned about for
quite a long time it's one of the
principal reasons why I called for the
review you know in a world where we're
where policy rates are going to be
closer to the effective lower bound then
just as a general matter we need to be
really strong on 2% inflation so I think
you know we we certainly don't want to
be seen as weak on inflation in it and I
don't believe we are in terms of the
dots your
right this is the first time I believe
we've had we've talked about cutting it
in the in the in the dot era I guess the
dot era began in January 2012 and you
know we're working our way through it
and I think it's just something we do I
you know that my view on the dots is
that they overall provide useful
information for people but that we need
to do our absolute best to explain what
they are and what they are not speaking
of which they are not a forecast of the
group they're not discussed or debated
at the meeting they're an input to
policy more than an output of policy and
they're also only the most likely case
so in a situation where there's
relatively high uncertainty there's the
most likely case but the second most
likely case might only be a little bit
less likely but that doesn't show up in
the dot the dot is either one thing or
it's another so I just would say that if
you pay too close attention to the dots
then you may lose sight of the larger
picture thank you Chris Condon Bloomberg
News mr. chairman if and when the
committee decides to cut rates I suspect
there will be a debate over whether to
move by 25 or 50 basis points indeed
there's a pretty substantial body of
academic literature arguing that a
central bank close to the zero lower
bound ought to act sooner and more
aggressively than it otherwise would
wondering what you think of that
prescription and if you could spend a
couple of minutes discussing the pros
and cons of a 50 basis point cut and how
you approach that question on a specific
question of that that's just something
we haven't really engaged with yet and
it will depend very heavily on incoming
data and and the evolving risk picture
as we move forward so it would be so
nothing I can say about that is specific
to the near-term question that we face
more generally though the research you
refer to essentially notes that in a
world where you are closer to the effect
of lower bound it's why research kind of
shows this it's it's wise to to react
for example to prevent a weakening from
turning into a prolonged weakening
sort of an ounce of prevention is worth
a pound of cure
so I think that is that is a valid way
to think about policy in this era I
don't know and it's it's always in the I
think it's in the minds of policymakers
all the you know during this era because
it's it's it's well understood to be
correct again I don't know what what
that means in terms of the size of a
particular rate cut coming forward
that's going to depend heavily upon you
know the actual data and the evolving
risk picture Donna Borak with CNN thanks
chairman Powell a Democratic
presidential candidate Elizabeth Warren
has provided a proposal to revalue the
u.s. dollar to in order to address
concerns about rising trade deficits the
President himself has routinely
complained about the strength of the
u.s. dollar saying it has resulted in
quote tremendous close quote competitive
advantage with countries like China and
others do you think that an overvalued
dollar has been a drag on America's
global competitiveness and would you
support an intervention of some kind on
this issue the US Treasury has
responsibility for exchange rate policy
not to Fed and we don't comment in that
sense on the level of the dollar we have
a responsibility for maximum employment
and stable prices and we use our tools
to achieve that of course we we do that
through changing financial conditions
and one of those is the dollar but we
don't target the dollar it's just
something that we don't do in fact
central banks or other nations when they
get together routinely adopt a
communique that says we will target our
domestic economic and financial
conditions and not our exchange rate and
using monetary policy and that includes
the United States that includes the g20
communique that we adopted ten days ago
so I'm not the right person to ask about
about that sort of dollar policy
innovation
you
according to the dot plot I mean if the
most likely case is that you will have
to cut rates in the next 18 months and
given some of the concerns about you
know policy needing to react sooner and
more aggressively what would have been
the downsides to cutting rates now why
not just cut them now so why not didn't
why not now
and I would say there was not much
support for cutting rates now at this
meeting there was as you see a number of
people wrote down rate cuts but all of
those but apparently one felt that that
it would be better to see more - before
moving and and I gave a couple reasons
why that is the case first it's just the
fact that some of these developments are
so recent that we want to to see whether
whether that whether they'll sustain so
we felt that it would be better to get a
clearer picture of things and that we
would in fact learn a lot about these
developments in the near term ultimately
the question we're gonna be asking
ourselves is are these risks going to be
continuing to weigh on the outlook and
we will act as needed including promptly
if that's appropriate and use our tools
to extent to sustain the expansion
yeah thank you for doing this chairman
Edward Lawrence from Fox Business
Network how do you reconcile the
conflicting economic data coming in you
know one hand you have strong overall
growth consumer spending is strong on
the other hand manufacturing numbers
were a little bit weaker you have growth
and jobs but coming in a little weaker
and then you have low inflation and then
specifically what data are you looking
at that you decided not to have a rate
cut well you gave a pretty good picture
I mean it's it's a it's a complicated
picture and you know the answer is we
look at all of it but I would say the
big pieces of it are this the the
baseline outlook has been a good one and
that has basically been consumer
spending coming back up in the second
quarter that has that is coming true
and consumer spending is at a healthy
level and that makes sense you've got a
tight labor market you've got companies
in surveys saying that labor is scarce
you've got workers in surveys saying
that jobs are plentiful
you've got wages going up you've got
high levels of household confidence so
all of that underlying fundamentals for
the consumer spending part of the
economy which is 70% of the economy is
quite solid job creation if you take a
three-month average is still well above
you know the level of entry into the
workforce so that part of the economy is
solid
you mentioned manufacturing and we're
seeing this all around the world
manufacturing investment and trade have
been have been weaker it's not solely a
domestic issue and and it may be that
there are a range of factors that are
contributing to that including for
example what China has done over the
last couple of years in in working to
bring down its leverage some of it may
be uncertainty over over your supply
chains due to trade developments the
Boeing 737 issues may be contributing in
their own way so they're lower oil
prices are contributing to lower
investment although they're also leading
to lower gas prices which supports
spending so there are many many things
there isn't any one thing that explains
it all but it's it is it's a sum
they were watching but you do see growth
in services so you this pattern around
the world of weak manufacturing but
growth in the far larger part of the
services economy which has led to low
unemployment good job creation rising
wages so that that's kind of the the two
big pieces of it that you see then you
see the cross currents if you lay the
cross currents on top of that concerns
about global growth and trade
developments you have the full picture
and I think what that picture what we
took away from that picture is that we'd
like to see more that we do see these
risks and what we want to do is we want
to watch and see whether they continue
to weigh upon the outlook Michael McKee
Bloomberg television on the radio if
consumer spending is solid and business
investment has been slowed by
uncertainty I'd like to get your
thinking on what a Fed rate cut would do
have you modeled the additional growth
and inflation you might get from a rate
cut can you identify any sectors that
would benefit from a lower cost of
capital or is this really about the Fed
being the only game in town well we we
have the tools we have and we're
committed and sworn to use them to
support economic activity and they do
support economic activity through
through a number of number of channels
that are reasonably well understood some
more directly tied to interest rates
than others but we do generally believe
that that our interest rate policy can
can support demand and support visit
business investment as well and so we we
will we'll really use those tools and
use them as we see is appropriate to
achieve our objectives which really are
to sustain this expansion and I would
just make a note of that the reason why
we say sustain the expansion is you're
seeing now for the for the first time
you know communities that are being
brought into the benefits of this
expansion that hadn't been earlier
you're ten years deep into this and
that's something we heard quite a lot at
the conference in Chicago on the review
and I just would say that's why we think
it's one of the reasons why we think
it's so important to
sustained the expansion keep it keep it
going because we really are benefiting
groups that haven't seen you know this
kind of prosperity in a long time policy
can solve those problems so we take the
crew you know we we take the cross
currents as a given and we have our
tools I don't you know we we don't we
react to anything in principle that
could undermine our achievement of our
dual mandate goals maximum employment
stable prices is worthy of our attention
and can call forth a policy response and
that's just how we look at it um hi
Victoria we done with Politico you've
said that the Fed doesn't take
short-term political considerations into
account and you've defended the feds
independence so I was wondering is there
a point at which you think that publicly
or privately you should push back on the
president's criticisms rather than
ignoring him and also do you think that
you and the president have the same
goals when it comes to monetary policy
you know I don't I don't discuss elected
officials publicly or privately really
so I I would just say that we are at the
Fed we're deeply committed to carrying
out our mission and and also that our
independence from direct political
control we see as an important
institutional feature that has served
both the economy in the country well
Nancy Marshall cancer with marketplace
share Paul are you concerned that new
digital currencies like Libre which
Facebook unveiled this week could
undermine the Fed and
erode your power to influence the
economy and did anyone from Facebook
talk with anyone at the Fed before Libre
was unveiled this week so on your
specific question of digital currencies
replacing central bank currencies I
think we're a long way from that yeah
and of course the so I think we're a
long way from that digital currencies
are in their infancy so essentially not
too concerned about but you know the
central bank's no longer being able to
carry out monetary policy because of
crypto currencies or digital currencies
you know Facebook I believe has made
quite broad rounds and around the world
really with regulators supervisors and
lots of people to discuss their plans
and that that certainly includes us and
we're you know it's something we're
looking at we meet with a broad broad
range of private sector firms all the
time on financial technology and there's
just a tremendous amount of innovation
going on out there you know their
potential benefits here they're also
potential risks particularly of a
currency that could you know that could
potentially have large application so I
would echo what what governor Carney
said which is that we we will wind up
having quite high expectations from a
sort of safety and soundness and
regulatory standpoint if they do decide
to go forward with something you know we
have we don't have plenary authority
over crypto currencies as such they play
into our world through consumer
protection and money laundering and
things like that but I would say that
you know through through international
forums you know we we have significant
input into into the payment system and
and you know as you know play an
important role in the payment system
here in the United States
thank you Jim about Greg Robb from
MarketWatch I want to take you back to
Chicago and the review of your monetary
policy strategy and something
interesting I think is developing is
that outside experts are excited and are
like the idea of the Fed shifting your
inflation target up to 4% around there
roughly I guess they think that that
would you know help monetary policy and
that there's no 2% is not like
sanctimonious or anything or whatever
sacred it seems like you've taken that
off the table so I was wondering if you
could discuss that have you taken it off
the table and then if so why or and
what's your thoughts on that thank you
we have we've said that we wouldn't look
at raising the the target rate for
inflation we did say that and and the
reason is it's become a global norm 2%
we our statutory mandate is price
stability and so we're actually taking a
less we're looking at less radical ideas
such as how to make the 2% inflation
objective more credible this gives me a
chance to say a couple things about the
review and Chicago in particular so it's
a new thing for us it's something that I
thought it was both appropriate
important for us to do it'll be a year
long or even longer process looking at
our strategy tools and communications
and it's it's meant to be a way to open
ourselves up to let the sunshine in and
have dialogue and criticism with the
constituencies that we serve we've had a
series of Fed listens around the country
at every Reserve Bank and we had an
academic conference earlier this month
with seven papers written and criticized
and leading global experts but I'll just
say again that the heart of the
conference was the two panels on with
practitioners in low and moderate-income
who live in low and moderate income
communities and are part of those
communities and they were there I think
people were quite struck by their
intervention which was really you know
normally around how important maximum
employment ISM what it means in their
communities you know the idea being they
haven't had you know a bull market in
these communities they haven't had just
a booming economy what they have have is
low unemployment lots of social problems
and just now you have you know companies
who want to hire and are bringing people
into the lake finding opportunities for
people to come into the labor force to
an extent not seen in quite a long time
and that is um I think you know for
someone who does this work that was very
focusing and and motivating to so I
think everybody thought you know that's
that was really quite worth doing I mean
there was there was some thought at the
beginning that we should some people
recommended that we just talked to you
know econ PhDs about this but no that's
not what we chose to do and we're glad
this is the choice we made but even
those two panels that you just
referenced the people that spoke they
when they were asked about you know 2%
inflation or higher inflation they kind
of shrugged their shoulders
you know so it is 4% inflation radical
to enter who I I don't think it's um I
don't think it's a practical alternative
and and I'll tell you why I think you
see disinflationary pressures around the
world you see central bank's having a
hard time getting inflation up to their
close to their objective we've done
better than other large central banks
who were better not you know open
economies like the UK where that where
where you you have big currency moves
that move inflation around so but it's
quite challenging to get inflation it's
been even with very high levels of
resource utilization inflation has been
lingering and and not getting back up to
target in a sustained symmetric kind of
away so saying that you're gonna go for
4% i I wonder how credible that would be
John Hilton with American Banker I have
a question about the feds or I guess the
bank regulators leverage lending
guidance from 2013 as you know the GAO
had a letter saying that they thought it
was a rule and it sort of went away but
yet leverage lending is a resource of
concern you yourself has said have said
that credit underwriting quality seems
to be deteriorating somewhat lately and
that the Fed has tools to to supervise
banks and to prevent leveraged lending
from becoming too much of an issue I
want to know what the is is the is the
2013 guidance still representative of
the sort of feds thinking about
leveraged lending and does the Fed have
any intent intention to either issue
like a leveraged lending rule or a new
guidance that is less problematic or is
the plan to just kind of carry on with
supervision as as your as you are these
are the the 2013 guidance is not binding
and that's what came out of the GAO
review but that's really the beginning
of this of the story you know we we we
have the authority we need to examine
the banks for safety and soundness
exposure so this the first thing you
start with as a bank supervisor is the
risks that the banks are taking to
themselves through their portfolio
through the risks that they're running
and and the pipeline you know the
obligations that they've undertaken to
underwrite deals and so we monitor that
very carefully so do the banks and you
see exposures that are much smaller than
they were before the crisis and by the
way we test that regularly in the in the
stress tests we impose very large losses
on those portfolios so we kind of have a
sense of what that is whereas before the
crisis there was a lot of lack of a lack
of knowledge about what the losses would
be so that's where it starts for us in
supervision is the risks that the banks
running it you know running on their own
books and to themselves and to and to
each other so and that I feel I feel
like that is that's in a good place but
we never we never say mission
accomplished on that we will keep you
know keep monitoring that carefully
what's happened though is the the paper
is now owned by market based vehicles
collateralized loan obligations mutual
funds and things like that and so we now
have you know we have a good sense of
domestically of where that paper is I
think internationally not as much in the
Financial Stability Board is actually
looking more carefully at that and we
you know we monitor those vehicles to to
see what they are and they're actually
pretty stable II funded in the sense
that there's no run risk but there's
still macroeconomic risk and you know
this is something that we we take very
seriously and that the the the F sock
the financial stability Oversight
Council is looking at and you know we
call it out as a macroeconomic risk but
it's not really a financial stability
risk in the sense that it could
undermine the ability of the financial
system to do its job of intermediate and
credit is there any intention is there
any plan on the part of the Fed or other
regulators to sort of create any
additional clarity for or
inconsistency really that's the other
point of guidance right is to to make
sure everyone knows kind of what the
supervisory expectations are for
leveraged lending and for a role for
anything for that matter there's
anything else coming or is it just gonna
remain kind of like bilateral kind of
conversations with banks you know I I
think I think the issue isn't that the
banks don't understand what the rules
are the issue is that the risk isn't in
the banks it's in it's out in those
market-based vehicles so I don't I don't
you know I no longer I'm day-to-day
involved in this as I was before I took
this job but my sense is though that
that's that's really not the the problem
I'm not saying it's perfect but I think
we do understand what what risks the
banks are running and really the
question is how concerned should we be
about large holdings by market-based
vehicles that I meant
and and what risks do they present and
we're very carefully assessing that and
we continue to take all these risks
seriously you know I gave a little
speech about this a few weeks ago so I
Brian Chung with Yahoo Finance I'm just
wondering if you could expand a little
bit on the labor market so the statement
noted that the labor market still
remains strong but the May job support
that we saw missed on estimates but the
unemployment rate still stayed at 3.6
percent I'm wondering how you reconcile
that with the fact that we only got 3.1
percent year-over-year wage growth in
that report what does that tell you
about employment and by all standards
compared to say a month ago or a year
ago are we closer or farther away from
full employment that's you know we have
to be closer because more jobs are being
created than people are running the
labor force the unemployment rate is is
lower you know but by just lots and lots
of numbers the the labor market isn't is
in a good place
you mentioned wages so the level of
wages is very consistent with with a
with what it should be in a sense that
it's approximately equal to inflation
plus productivity increases on an hourly
basis so what's I guess a little
surprising though is that you could
reach these levels of unemployment late
you know long into a cycle let's say and
not see even higher wages they're
pushing up on inflation because wages at
this level even though they're growing
at a healthy rate at an appropriate rate
they're not they're not growing at a
rate that would provide much upward
thrust for inflation so you know we
watch we watch all this very carefully
and I think we're very careful about not
assuming that were you know that would
that there's no more slack in the labor
market you know we've all lived through
you know when I got to the Fed we were
in the 8% plus range and it's just going
down and down and down and you haven't
seen wages picked up you haven't seen
real signals that were that we're at
maximum employment you have seen a
tightening labor market you know that
it's if the surveys and as I mentioned
will all show that the labor market is
tightened but not over tightened
hi Jean Young with Market News I wanted
to ask did the FOMC discuss a change to
its balance sheet policy at this meeting
perhaps ending runoffs earlier than
planned and with the committee be
inclined to do something like that if it
lowers rates before September so of
course we haven't made any decisions yet
balance sheet runoff is is very close to
the end of its of its planned life I
would say this if we do provide more
accommodation again we haven't really
addressed this but if we do provide more
accommodation we'll certainly keep in
mind what we said earlier this year
which is that we'll always be willing to
adjust balance sheet policy so that it
serves our dual mandate objectives thank
you very much